on the big island of Hawaii lava
continues to flow from my own Aloha the
world's largest active volcano several
channels are coursing down the sides of
the 13 000 foot high volcano Mauna Loa
had been dormant for almost four decades
the eruptions led to a rush of tourists
and a lot of calculating for scientists
Jonathan Vigliotti reports
as lava from Mauna Loa continues to
yield spectacular images what spewing
out has slowed considerably at this
point we're only dealing with one active
fissure which is Fisher three in one act
of Love of littlewood the only current
threat Remains the main Highway that
crosses Hawaii Island the flows are now
less than three miles away clearly
visible but they're oozing less than 50
yards per hour meaning it takes about
two hours just to move the length of a
football field geologists say it could
take a week if at all before the lava
reaches the highway there is also luck
there is is no imminent threat to
residents on the west side or South side
of the island at this time if the
eruption took a different path the city
of Hilo could have been in the bullseye
instead Islanders are enjoying Nature's
Marvel and native Hawaiians are paying
their respects
the eruption has at times sent lava
hundreds of feet up into the air nobody
knows when it will stop at this point
and what damage if any it could cause
five days into the eruption of the
world's largest active volcano the lava
much less of a threat and more of a
treat
and officials say only one of the four
vents that erupted remains active it's
still unclear how long the lava will
continue to flow it could be days or
even weeks for CBS Saturday morning
Jonathan Vigliotti Hawaii